[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 se va acercando nuestra hora de
desayuno Daniela Usted dijo que íbamos a
hablar de la baguetti por supuesto lo
vamos a hablar pero más adelante porque
primero Tenemos que hablar del dinero de
la economía
comenzamos con el repaso de la relación
económica entre Estados Unidos y Francia
porque estaba a propósito de la visita
de Maluma Corona Washington y Raúl pues
Estados Unidos y Francia tienen una
relación comercial bastante dinámica en
2021 según datos de la Casa Blanca la
Unión Americana importó desde la nación
gala bienes y servicios por un poco más
de 50.000 millones de dólares también
exportó algo menos de 30 mil millones de
dólares lo que le da a Francia una
ventaja de 20.000 millones sobre su
socio los equipos de transporte las
máquinas los químicos y los cueros son
lo que más comercian bilateralmente Dani
Y hay un tema en específico que
seguramente lo van a abordar los
presidentes cuál es y hablaba que
Durante los últimos meses se trata de la
ley de reducción de la inflación que
vayan aprobó en agosto con gastos
históricos en iniciativas climáticas y
energéticas y que Francia y otros países
de la Unión Europea han considerado como
proteccionista que afecta sus intereses
se trata de una ley de 750 mil millones
de dólares que busca atacar la inflación
dentro de los grandes cambios propone un
impuesto mínimo para las corporaciones
con ingresos de al menos un mil millones
de dólares al año también permite que
Medicare negocie el precio de ciertos
medicamentos recetados y en ocasiones
específicas Determine su valor con base
en la inflación y entre otros contempla
y esto lo más polémico para estos países
de la Unión Europea más de 400 400 mil
millones de dólares en nuevas
inversiones para impulsar la industria
de la energía verde es justamente este
punto el que rechaza esta Unión de 27
países ya que les otorga créditos
Fiscales a aquellos consumidores que
compren vehículos eléctricos fabricados
en Estados Unidos dicen que va a afectar
su producción bueno Dani y nos quedamos
en ese país para hablar de la posible
huelga ferroviaria que puede enfrentar
en Estados Unidos vamos a estar Raúl muy
pendientes este miércoles porque la
cámara baja se dispone a probar una
legislación para adoptar un acuerdo
tentativo entre los trabajadores
ferroviarios y sus operadores este
enfrentamiento entre sindicatos que
representan a más de 115 mil
trabajadores con sus empleadores amenaza
con detener los envíos de alimentos y
combustibles y dejar varados a Los
viajeros ferroviarios a partir del 9 de
diciembre ellos piden no solamente que
les aumenten sus salarios esto ya lo
hicieron con algunos en septiembre
pasados sino que tengan derecho a días
de incapacidad pagos y eso es lo que
discutirá el legislativo hasta ahora de
mayoría demócrata el jefe de estado es
un llamado al congreso
le pregunté los cuatro principales
líderes del Congreso si estarían
dispuestos a hablar sobre lo que vamos a
hacer desde ahora hasta navidad en
términos de legislación y hay mucho por
hacer incluida la resolución de la
huelga de trenes y lo que estamos
haciendo ahora y el congreso Creo tiene
que actuar para prevenirla no es una
decisión fácil pero creo que tenemos que
hacerlo la economía está en riesgo
bueno Daniela y ahora sí la baqueta es
el patrimonio y material de la UNESCO
declarado el día de hoy Qué delicia pero
no solo es un símbolo culinario sino que
también representa mucho dinero así es
Raúl Lo prometido es deuda se lo había
prometido en la primera Crónica y acá le
tengo las cifras Francia había
presentado su candidatura con los
siguientes datos vamos a ver en 1970
había 55 mil panaderías artesanales es
decir una panadería por cada 790
habitantes y hoy existen 35.000 o una
por cada 2000 habitantes según el
gobierno Eso significa la desaparición
de un promedio de 400 panaderías al año
en la última mitad del siglo la baqueta
es tan importante en Francia que cada
segundo se venden 320 unidades para un
consumo anual de 6000 millones de barras
que se venden normalmente a un euro pues
vemos con la inflación de pronto puede
estar un poquito más costoso
ya no les va a decir Claro que sí de
Erika olavarría quien se encuentra en
una panadería pues ya me imagino que se
habrá comido casi toda la ba